So my name is Ben and today. November twenty first
two thousand and thirteen at the
Clinton hello for our street astore project oral history.
Where were you born.
Oh I was born in Cleveland Ohio.
Came to New York to go to college
in ninety nine hundred seventy
two
in Manhattan.
So it's not a real story.
Because it was more
considered to live and a lot of people it's hard to even get them to
come visit us and so I had no plans
to move to. And I knew nothing about Brooklyn and
I realized I was kind of blinkered. Back
that it was maybe all
I could really do to learn about Manhattan and New York City and I didn't know
anything
about it and I thought it was kind of strange place where people
talked and
then the other way it
wasn't moved to Brooklyn for
really because it was where I could
afford to live and I don't know the
really more affluent I couldn't
get that much and
I said I
never. I
moved to
Brooklyn.
I
don't and I write. A
lot and.
That was really.
That kind of lived up to the refutation of a very
dangerous neighborhood that day. And the person is not really
funny
but I I signed the agreement with
the artist to snark to lies and she
was very kind of hard headed together person who knew how to manage
her career and I didn't find till after I had signed that the reason she
was moving out blitz because her husband her boyfriend had
been seriously injured by kind of muggers or something outside
their outside the subway station and so they had hit him over the head with
it to life and he almost died
so that was that
was
not that you know not that surprising given
that this woman
was something of a
smoothie to it it's
maybe she didn't let that slip until she
had lived in Dumbo. But it was kind
of really it was the two big projects.
I'm not sure that their houses are in and was very much.
A feeling like those people have been here kind of don't. You know to get them
out of the way. Now closer to song like super duper super
do very very sad neighborhood that you in
even to recognize it's a beautiful name and
that wealthy neighborhood.
You know. I did. Sure there's a lot of beautiful people in the fire and expect them but I
only experience kind of the scary people. So
anyway
so I
had to move out of there because she
actually decided to come back to the. Well.
And
by that time I had a
boyfriend
and we ended
up finding a place we could afford here in Clayton.
And it was one bedroom for you in a brown stone for eight hundred
dollars a month.
So that was the first of a happy home in Brooklyn. So that
was my name when I first got here.
Year that
was
eighty. Something
Heidi. And you know
quite a few years ago.
Compared to my sister in Park Slope.
It was actually more friendly. Here we found it was just it was a
family near here and beautiful in the spring there had to find.
The beautiful Victorian town. So I I'd like to film
the beginning even though it was it was also kind of
rough and able to back down off of the fear and they were
like you know more like people burning.
It garbage cans they burn stuff to keep warm and a cold night like street dogs kind
of
wondered.
But it was still a lot of middle class. And I kind of
met them. They were family so that was really
nice
and. We got married. It
was lead to a happy happy ending for me I might
say because it's not always going right.
And we started a family and we moved to
a two bedroom condo wanted to have dad. And parking the
car and
avenues
and. The
leap in there.
And that was the housing preservation and development concept it was they had advice like
that middle class condos and I think they
did successfully stabilize middle class neighborhood because.
There was a sense that there's been a couple subsequent real estate crashes.
But the neighborhood continues
to stay on how it's almost destabilized in the
other direction that it's going crazy that hi hi it's kind of
the same.
But when we moved in we
had we I was pregnant when we moved in
very
quick and I couldn't
even I couldn't
even be there because I was hospitalized with gestational
diabetes when we were planning when we would the day came to move.
And so my husband had to do it.
With the help of some men with him
then
it was. It was just it was a lot it was just so bad I don't even know how.
Right now.
Well. By now
we my husband had a good job and I became a stay at home
mom for seven years the type really
to. This Great say. I know there's many different ways it's not
good for everybody.
And I have some friends in the kind of little children and it was
just some visiting back and forth every day
and and going to the playground and
seeing people
and those who are you know
the happy years and the irony
is
that we would be like sitting on ice to kind
of well neighborhood in some kind of crack crack I say back before my SO I
but it was still we were like you know like they're well you know we're like really high
functioning people on the you know that. And then began to come home with
their suits on in the little kids would come to
me. And the moms who would you know go inside and make dinner or
something and that and we were kind of like you know our cars were not getting raises that
we weren't. Having all these justices. Some of the lower income people are
having and now the back I know you know our value is gone up
maybe five times that Lee. But the other people I know the more affluent
people and we've had we are struggling more economically.
We've got a decrease in our economic be kind of going up and down but at least.
It's just enough. We had stability to have child
raising years. So that's good.
But it is emblematic the middle class is having a harder time people get people
get downsized allowed the corporations
don't want to.
Have loyalty to
their way out there and. So
that's kind of nice. And now.
These web developers I don't even know what the well off people are maybe people with family
money live in the name of right now. You do see kind of
eerie people who seem very carefree like they can just buy whatever they want you
know walking around. They have cute little kids you
know so that they have nannies
and oversized C.N.N. is pushing expensive you
know sensitive strollers down the
street
you know a cute little kid.
So that's kind of
the in a nutshell kind of the story of me
being so clean and Clinton you know but I made I did make friends and
I do feel
like. Sometimes I think we should all
cash out you know and move someplace we can really afford to get financial stability but I would
hate to. You know where would I live
with connections
and friends my community garden my church you know.
I don't know actually green acres and Franklin green.
Yes I know the one that people
like that's where that's that's the not
the end of the story the most recent
cap that
well yeah I do have some very
nice memories of this library.
That's you
now. Coventry jazz concert here.
In just a
commune all proud jazz guys and there's an audience of
maybe maybe you know maybe twelve people with the kids and.
I was proud of my kids because they could see you know
I pay attention and the jazz guys was very cool Cassidy was just.
You know it takes a trained really mentally
challenged really really free concert in your local
library and then another fun memory was coming
here because my oldest was very good at our
county and even had a young age to make me sick
so far so down and he could sell some of
these little bit more complicated
and or Downey sessions so we could not miss that.
So we found out.
You know are both still to really call it we made it here to this
very cold weather. You know at the dark and we can do
it golden you know warm weight and origami ladies sitting
there and she had
come from her sick bed and who worries was she could hardly come up with
she really wanted to do this or the session. She took our
nominee very seriously just kind of. Make no sense
of humor but she was great for
her
and when I came in I saw there was an age limit because maybe
they didn't have little kids they just couldn't do it and my my kid was under the age limit.
But she could do that she could do those butterflies extensions. So
I
guess.
What I'll make up.
I
think
we made friends. And I will do retired she says.
She didn't want to do
and she. She.
But also the community I got very involved in the community garden for the last fifteen
years.
That's
my
stuff that sparked my interest because I
had planned on my condo I think
most of the Korean community at the condo. And the
employees suddenly employ the professional
landscape and they read everything they
had to move. Some of my plans and we directed it and I saw
this new garden opening up and I just that was myself you know it's a
home for my industry. I was
very open and then we appreciate it which a lot
of places you know it's like I don't know about you or your book.
But little by little.
You have been started by locals over the locals but
also the environmentalist group
called up by and high school.
I was an environmentalist.
Before and.
I had a lot to sort of McCain choose to come
to although I don't buy school but he came to come to councils.
And
using you know in renewable energy and.
And you know
it was actually I think it was started in two thousand.
Because it was shortly before nine eleven.
And it was got some context. The real estate
of the building next door. They basically couldn't sell it at almost
any price. And
now. With only a couple of million
don't
think Canada did something
during the.
Divil
that it's a good question because he always he drives a
car coke to do like
shopping.
I know one hand I do try to patronize some of the locals. But there are a lot of
things that didn't make you couldn't you know like good.
Really. Well it baby store. You know I had to go
to other neighborhoods to do a lot of
shopping but I had actually lose for you
know before I. And I found out it seems like great
to live in a futile upscale neighborhood. But oh over
time it's depressing if you can consciously Pastore the restaurant that you can afford to go
to so in some ways going to the local little mom and pop stores
and buying penny candy that was all the shopping and that was a lot you
know I was in my price range.
I
was really happy or if I happen to get a really good
deal in the new and expensive neighborhood I think over
time I would be right. Just behind penny candy
and and a few sheets
in their last few months
now too and I mean the little bit at the end of the first
book in the eighty's and if you are going to fight the
wars that actually went out
of the kind of decide to it now.
And you know
was actually really the sky kind
of kind of junk
store guy because he probably you
know that kind of seems like there was like a muffin story kind
of like coffee and muffin. This is like a gentrified
type of an idea and I like that little store.
But it couldn't quite hang on extremists and
now. You know
at the store he expresses you
know everything everywhere
down. The flame working to
the
yeah oh yeah that was. But there
was this is there for like maybe ten years at the mountain and
I know that
because you know back in the eighty's.
You know we couldn't even believe it was honey bee couldn't even believe we were thinking
like that so they're very helpful to try and bring a good and
upscale classic Italian I child to our club that there is and it's still there.
And we've got the same thing
about down there kind of
like I'm not saying not to do it was OK now I cannot
believe that playing out is money into making the call nice it's good to have
like five months and still are two people tapping away
on Apple computers.
Now anything that opens up it wouldn't surprise
me not to remind my kids
that it wasn't that I don't I got my Africa
that's pretty crazy.
What any of the parks
you
would go to
the week of the green
color me to
see it's
not the last. Yeah.
Just you know
the police you know and.
That's the red type which is the little.
Shoe it is that we consider that like too dangerous to
get and for some reason this is the case and
gentrified just before.
You see
my guide to get an internship for a year or two. That's what a green park with the
from the conservancy and so I got
lucky.
That.
Yes that's.
We did i could drive to the park in part of their ninety's
taking it
to school
actually. I managed to get them
to a private school. And they went until eighth
grade and then they went to Brooklyn just for a year and
yeah. Yeah I
see I see the schools. Hopefully they're improving
out here because I think they used to be
pretty you know I
actually took my own this mine too. So I don't even remember
the name I wanted to pre-K..
A local
school
and
you know bad guy and it was like ninety two but they literally had
to call the police at
that like craft session. Her parents. Fight broke
out you know it was I mean it was really painful
and we're fighting for people that cared about that.
And yet you know. So
I found for some reason the parents around they had like a book that was a magazine about handguns
and
think
this really is a librarian facing all people I guns let me get a magazine about hand. And have a
good deal it is just me says James I consider like confiscating
you know. The way they gave
the
school was not a good school. They did have like twenty three percent
a grade level. Do better next year.
I think you know that we see the kind said there was more that was kind of
a
town character kind of feeling to go
really kind of stayed for
Social it up hopefully
more
educational emphasis would be better.
I guess. Did you learn from this time in life
you know.
Yeah
he did learn a lot
about the value of being in one place takes a
long time to really understand there
were doubts about people
and to sions and the
environment
and
you know I was the general liberal but I didn't really understand everything
that was going to
to
really you know step by step getting to
know what
you're good you know outside you know good. Besides
just kind of being
like she
couldn't
live in that live or something that was actually getting to
know that I think
and this
is if you have to go out there.
And that is a very valuable. I think you feel that. You know. And
I felt
like. I got me to
come in you know
like you can feel like oh I have it. I have a great here but I can't really very
much because I don't know all
these really scary good. So if you we're If you
feel a little better obviously you could
say to the country.
Well mainly black Americans who
is going
to really you
know I don't even know
that so much that we could be people who can make
and stuff like that so that was fun for me
to hear.
And also like to usual church going
to church but not.
Not
going to like
it that you didn't like the people
here
really anything you want to talk about.
I think we did he did. Thanks. Thank you
so
much pain. OK.